THE PORN JOURNAL IS COMING! THE PORN JOURNAL
IS COMING! Viva la revolucion!
Hey everyone, Laci Green here. We talk about
a lot of disciplines here on DNews and cover
a wide variety of scientific journals as well,
from the super mainstream like PLOS 1 to the
nichey and obscure like the Journal of Wine
Research. And this week, a new scholarly journal
birthed itself into the world -- and it's
all about porn. WHICH MAKES ME VERY EXCITED.
Porn may seem more "extra curricular" than
academic, but there are definitely a lot of
big scientific questions about pornography
that are unknown. Considering the fact that
(1) it's an industry larger than all the leading
tech companies COMBINED, (2) that porn sites
are more widely accessed than netflix, amazon,
and twitter COMBINED, (3) that it makes up
⅓ of all internet data -- I feel like heyyyyy!
Maybe we should try to put some data to our
questions.
While the idea of a porn studies journal might
seem kind of silly, believe it or not, there
really hasn't been a whole lot of scholarly
study about porn. There are studies here aand
there, but for the most part they're not repeated
to test their validity and a lot of the conclusions
about porn come from peoples' anecdotes and
theories. Theories have their place too, but
we have to test them to draw conclusions!
And fortunately, rampant internet porn provides
us with an enormous pool of data to work with.
From that data I hope to see things liiiiike:
HOW DOES PORN AFFECT US? OR DOES IT EVEN AT
ALL? Does the age that you first watch porn
matter? What does porn say about sexual norms
and attitudes, if anything? Is porn addiction
a real thing in the brain? What's going on
with some of the strange fantasies in porn?
What about the people who do porn - how are
they doin? Are there any links between porn
consumption and personality type? Occupation
type? Political ideology? Or does porn usage
transcend time and space in a universal vacuum
of nakedness?
These are my questions peeps. AND I WANT ANSWERS.
I've been picking through the first issue
and there are several interesting pieces.
My favorites being "The Problem of Sexual
Fantasies", and "Porn and Sex Education, Porn
As Sex Education". I'll link those below since
the journal has allowed, for the moment, public
access.
Stay tuned for more updates as the studies
get rollin. In the meantime, what question
about porn would you like to see scientists
address? .........I'm opening myself up to
hell in the comments right now....and I don't
even care...... Thanks for joining me for
DNews everyone! I'll cya next time.